aymeric la vie comme les autres au stade
de la sat hier à nantes l'école de
football qui s'appelait c'est là que
jérémy toulalan
aujourd'hui jaune professionnelle ou et
si nantes atlantique débuté je sentais
qu'il avait clairement dans l'euphorie
qualité des possibles unitaire et
d'ailleurs je lui dont deux en poussins
et
il me disait toujours aucune conclusion
je voudrais bien devenir trop voudrait
bien devenir pro ya dans mon petit coeur
des parents des des parents de jérémy
habitait le quartier où l'on rit pendant
quatre ans le petit solal on jouera à la
5e
à l'époque vous aviez tenu comme tous
les gosses étaient en bleu 15 et 29 ans
les royaumes et puis on voulait tuer moi
personnellement déçu de bayern munich
pourquoi le bayern de munich le parce
que mon père était faire les
déplacements là bas et ils m'avaient
ramener un maillot de là-bas à l'âge de
10 ans direction la jonelière des
équipes de jeunes du fc nantes jusqu'au
professionnel avant les grands débuts le
19 mars dernier en ligue des champions
face au bayern de munich tient qu'à ce
jour là jérémy toulalan portait le
numéro 34
les barbus à la chambre avec des
chanteurs des premiers nique et puis on
a été prévenus le dimanche et le lundi
on partait de mardi en jouant cette
saison jérémy toulalan s'installe dans
l'équipe du fc nantes atlantique au
poste de milieu de terrain
déjà trois fois titulaire en ligue 1 il
sait qu'il a tout le temps de faire sa
place
il a eu 19 ans
au début du mois